we're gonna have a conversation now with
Republican senator Tom Cotton of
Arkansas who has been on the campaign
Trail supporting his party's nominees
that include Senate candidates Herschel
Walker in Georgia and Dr mehmon Oz in
Pennsylvania Senator cotton also has a
new book out today it's called Only the
Strong reversing the left's plot to
sabotage American power in the book
cotton looks at Decades of U.S history
and makes the argument that progressives
and then Democrats have weakened the
country and done so intentionally
Senator cotton joins us now Senator good
morning congratulations on getting a
book launched into the world not an easy
thing I do want to get to the book but I
want to begin with this news from Paul
Pelosi and the Speaker of the House one
of your fellow elected officials a
break-in in her home her husband
assaulted and according to the
authorities uh the perpetrator was
looking for her to potentially break her
kneecaps wheel her into Congress as an
example of consequences what's your
reaction to all that
well Tony thanks for having me on it's a
terrible crime against Paul Pelosi I
wish him the very best in a full
recovery and we should throw the book at
the assailant this is just one more
example though of what we should always
do with violent criminals which is throw
the book at them we should do the same
thing to the person who tried to
assassinate Brett Kavanaugh the same
thing to all the agitators who are
protesting in violation of federal law
outside of Justice's homes and for that
matter not just speakers at the house or
Supreme Court Justices any common
Criminal Who attacks someone who rapes
who murders should have the book thrown
at them we need to crack down and get
tough on crime in this country that's
the solution to all of these heinous
crimes
senator for the moment I'd want to
separate out everyday violent crime and
what seems to be politically motivated
crime and and get your thoughts on
whether the temperature in the country
is just too high uh the misinformation
is just too much and that we're going to
see more not less political violence
going forward that's the concern people
in your own party have voiced that
concern
well you seem to arrange lunatics attack
both Democrats and Republicans alike I
don't think John Boehner 12 years ago
pointing out that Nancy Pelosi passed
Obamacare or Kevin McCarthy now point
out that she passed trillions of dollars
of spending that causes inflation led to
this you know apparent nudist activists
breaking into her home the simplest way
to stop crimes like this is to get tough
on crime it's not to try to stop
campaigning in the middle of a campaign
seven days for an election on legitimate
issues of public concern
and absolutely people should continue to
campaign on legitimate issues of public
concern no uh no debate there but to be
clear from your answers here I'm here
you don't see any connection between
things said in this country in
particular by people denying the results
of the 2020 election uh and the
motivations of as you call it this
madman in Paul Pelosi's house with
intentions against the speaker you don't
see a connection between the political
rhetoric and the actions of this
individual and other individuals
Tony no more connection than Chuck
Schumer going to the steps of the
Supreme Court and saying that Brett
Kavanaugh wouldn't know what hit him if
he issued rulings that Chuck Schumer
disagreed with and what did you have a
left-wing Hitman showing up at Brett
Kavanaugh's house to assassinate him the
answer to all of these crimes is to get
tough on crime and throw the book at
these criminals
all right Senator let's talk about this
book uh Only the Strong uh you know you
make the case in this book uh that
Democrats are not just making as you say
mistakes which Republicans have made but
are intentionally as you put it plotting
against America trying to weaken America
a design a decline by Design is how you
put it uh why'd you want to put this
book out right now
well after the Afghanistan Fiasco last
year Tony so many arcans asked me how
did this happen how did we lose to a
medieval band of savages in Afghanistan
I wanted to explain going back to the
origins of the modern Progressive
Movement with Woodrow Wilson the most
ideological man to ever become president
why so many on the Progressive left seem
to be weakening our country at best
these progressives are ambivalent about
America and they're openly hostile to
American power that's why you see them
undermining the foundation of American
power a strong and fearsome military a
prosperous free economy sovereignty at
our borders and freedom of action in the
world American energy production this is
not something that's just happening it's
not bad luck Joe Biden for instance in
the 2020 campaign said that he was going
to end fossil fuel production in America
that's why we have gas at almost four
dollars a gallon that's why people are
going to struggle to heat their homes in
some parts of the country this year so I
wanted to explain why this is happening
why it's driven by the lifts audio
logical Ambitions and also lay on a road
map for how we can recover American
power
Senator there is a lot at stake in these
midterm elections and there will be
points and counterpoints to everything
you just said there but I I am curious
looking ahead of 2024 as I know you have
as well you want to win in 2022 and then
take back the white house uh with your
resume Harvard Harvard U.S Army 101st a
ranger and now this book A lot of people
are looking at you and thinking he wants
it in 2024. am I right
well thanks Tony for even uh asking the
question but I just say it's one of my
drill sergeants you say in basic rifle
Marksmanship there's 50 meter targets
there's 300 meter targets there's a time
to hit the 300 meter Target but right
now the 50 meter Target is seven days
away and after this election will be
time to look towards 2024. one reason I
wanted to lay out this book though is to
explain to our fellow Americans what it
would take to turn around uh our country
what it would take to restore American
power and arrest the decline we've seen
under Barack Obama and now Joe Biden I
hope it'll be a good book for everyone
to read whether they're in public office
or whether they simply want better
elected officials in public office all
right Senator Tom Cotton I think people
heard you loud and clear waiting to take
his shot in 2024 the book Is Only the
Strong and it is on sale right now
Senator cotton thank you very much